one of the sort of side stories with
what's going on on twitter with this
reportedly accepted offer for elon musk
to purchase twitter and to take it
private one of the side stories that's
come up and many of you have emailed me
about it many of you have noticed how it
has affected my twitter account
is the significant number of uh
followers that many left-leaning
accounts have lost on twitter and so i'm
going to explain this story
as i currently know it and i'm going to
try to be as accurate and precise as
possible without going beyond what we
know and what's been said because it is
still sort of a developing story so the
way that this started is right around
sunday monday tuesday when we learned
about this effort that has reportedly
been accepted by twitter although it's
not yet been approved it's been accepted
in principle but it hasn't happened and
it still may not for elon musk to buy
twitter
we started seeing overwhelming anecdotal
reports of high-profile twitter accounts
and verified twitter accounts reporting
losing huge numbers of followers
right in that period of time where it
started to become known that elon musk
may be buying twitter
and initially the assumption was before
twitter put out any statement you saw a
lot of venture capital and investment
type people saying what's happening here
is twitter is cleaning up the bots and
the fake accounts
for the sale because part of what you
need to this was the story they were
telling there was no evidence for this
but they were saying you know when
you're going to trip part of the
valuation is based on the number of
users and so you want to feel really
good that you can give an accurate
number of real people that are using the
service so you want to eliminate bots
and fake accounts
and it may be that the more followers
you have the more fake followers that
you have
it never struck me as accurate i don't
think that just an agreement in
principle would immediately start some
kind of algorithmic closure of accounts
believed to be fake or bots so it just
wasn't logical it's possible that would
be done
but the idea that it would start
instantly upon the news breaking of elon
musk's purchase it just didn't really
make any sense but the numbers were
pretty stunning a former president
barack obama who's one of the most
followed people on twitter maybe the
most followed
he lost more than 300 000 followers
after the announcement on monday
my verified account my tiny little teeny
weeny verified account lost about a
thousand followers in that monday
tuesday period um between sunday and
tuesday nancy pelosi lost like 13 000
followers elizabeth warren lost 14 000
followers bernie sanders lost 19 000
followers but then it appeared that not
everybody was actually losing followers
because some right wing accounts
were seeing massive dumps of new
followers come in um marjorie taylor
green the radical trumpet congresswoman
personally she's banned on twitter
but her congressional account is still
active i know whatever that's not even
the whether that makes sense or not it's
not the issue marjorie taylor green's
account
saw a record new 100 000 followers over
that two-day period i you know i lost a
thousand she gained a hundred thousand
so that can't be because of purging bots
because some people were gaining
followers and they seem to be mostly
right wingers well twitter has now
spoken out about it twitter says that
the follower changes that have been
observed are coming from quote natural
account terminations
uh a spokesperson at twitter who spoke
on the condition of anonymity said
the more high profile the account the
more of a fluctuation we've seen but
these are not bot closures this is just
people closing accounts and people
signing up so the current claim from
twitter is i lost a thousand followers
because a thousand of my followers were
genuinely mad that elon musk is buying
twitter and so they went and they closed
their twitter accounts and at the same
time marjorie taylor greene gained a
hundred thousand followers because i
guess
right wingers presumably happy that elon
musk is buying twitter
said i'm gonna make a twitter account or
i'm gonna take my dormant twitter
account and start following people like
marjorie taylor green because i'm ready
for the free speech and all of the
different things that elon musk is going
to bring uh ted cruz gained more than 50
000 followers matt gates gained about 25
000 followers right wing nut brazilian
president jair bolsonaro gained close to
a hundred thousand followers so
do we believe this do we believe this i
i mean if it it can't be that this was a
bot purge because the right wing
accounts are gaining followers
if the belief is these are the natural
reactions leftists are mad about elon
musk so they're closing accounts and
right wingers are thrilled about elon
musk buying it so they're signing up
if that's the case it's a concern
because of what it signals that twitter
may become
the other part of it is
i mean listen
it's striking me as a little bit of a
statistical improbability
that you would see such partisan changes
to followers so quickly it's just kind
of weird we work with algorithms all the
time and jankyuger tweeted something
similar we see
how these things have happened over long
periods of times on a time on youtube
and on different platforms
i just don't know that i buy it i i
don't know i'm not accusing anyone in
particular of lying maybe it's a
combination of things and of course if
the explanation that twitter is giving
is a lie well it's a concern that
twitter is lying so to me this is a red
flag either way
my personal
behavior on twitter is i continue to
mute every annoying account because
twitter has always been filled with lots
of right wing trolls i actually looked
at my account the other day
what it would look like without
thousands of trolls muted it would be
completely unusable and what's really
funny is there are people who have been
tweeting trash to me on twitter for
years they've had no idea that i can't
see their tweets
and for years that it made me laugh a
little bit that there's so many of them
but as far as what we know now twitter
saying the fluctuations left wingers
losing followers right wingers gaining
followers this is a reflection of
natural
uh account creation and deletion which
if true
raises real questions about what the
future of twitter looks like under elon
musk on today's bonus show we're going
to examine
elon musk's history of speech
as a defender or not of free speech
which has been very much at issue here
that'll be on today's bonus show
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video